اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم نزوح اكثر من 19 ال من
ارمن اقليم كارباخ ودخولهم ارمينيا
واذربيجان تبدا ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
الى الاقليم واشنطن تؤكد الالتزام بسياده
ارمينيا وتعلن عن مساعدات لسكان الاقليم
ول كرملين يقول انه لا يرى افكارا ملموسه
لدى واشطن بشان الوضع في
كارباخ نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي دمتري مدفيدف يقول انه لم يعد امام
موسكو سوى الصراع المباشر مع النيتو
والكرملين يتوعد باحراق دبابات ابرامز
الامريكيه التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا وموسكو
تعلن اسقاط مسيرات وصواريخ فوق بلغراد
والقرم بينما تؤكد كيف تعرض مناء اسماعيل
على الدنوب لهجوم
روسي غدات اعلان باريس اعتزامها سحب
قواتها من النيجر المجلس العسكري في
النيجر يقول ان جدول انسحاب القوات
الفرنسيه يجب ان يتم وفق اجل يتم التفاهم
بشانه مؤكدا ان نضال الشعب اثمر وان
البلاد تحتفل بخطوه جديده نحو
السياده نشطاء مدونون يهاجمون وزيره
الرياضه الفرنسيه املي كاستيرا بعد ان
كشفت خلال تصريحات صحفيه عن منع الحجاب
على الرياضيات الفرنسيات المشاركات في
الاولمبياد القادم الذي ستحتضنه فرنسا عام
2024 واعتبر القرار حلقه جديده من مسلسل
التضييق على الحريات في امان
الله